[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه
سينمائيه بارزه وتظاهره حاشده امام البيت
الابيض تنادي دو بقمع النظام للمحتاجين
وكاله الدوليه يزور طهران اليوم وايران
تضاعف قدرتها على تخصيب اليورانيوم
رغم الاقبال الضعيف هيئه الانتخابات
التونسيه تقول ان النسبه ايجابيه والنتائج
الاثنين
في مونديال كاس العالم بقطر منتخب التانجو
بقياده ميسي يواجه ديوك فرنسا ونجمهم بابي
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا البدايه من الاحتجاجات
في ايران وردود الفعل الدولي الغاضبه حيث
نظم المئه الايرانيين مظاهره حاشده في
العاصمه الامريكيه واشنطن متجهين نحو
البيت الابيض وهدف المتظاهرون امام البيت
الابيض مطالبين الرئيس الاستيقاظ وعدم
الاتفاق مع نظام الملاهي حسب تعبيرهم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
جول
هذا اول نظره متظاهرون وقفه احتجاجيه امام
السفاره الايرانيه في النمسا على خلفيه
القمع والاعدامات المتكرره التي تقوم بها
الحكومه الايرانيه كما طالب متظاهرون
باغلاق السفاره الايرانيه فيديا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
شاطر شاطر
[موسيقى]
شاطر
المتظاهرين بعضهم وصل حد الطريق
بمن فيهم الاطفال
حيث شرع سياسيون في مختلف انحاء اوروبا في
رعايه المحتاجين الايرانيين المسجونين على
امل ان تطر السلطات عبر تصويت الضوء على
حاله الظلم الفرديه للعدول عن اصدار احكام
بالسجن فترات طويله او تنفيذ احكام
بالاعدام
قيد الاحتجاج الان ممن لديه مراعي اوروبي
في المانيا قضيه الطفله الايرانيه سونيا
شريف ذات 16 عاما والتي قد تواجه عقوبه
الاعدام كذلك ما ارتبنا حاله محمد بروكلي
ب 19 عاما يواجه الاعدام الوشيك في سجن
رجاء شهر في مدينه كرج اضافه الى مغني
الراب المعارض المعتقل الصالح
وارميت عباسي ذات ال 20 عاما التي نقلتها
قوه الامن الى مستشفى في كرج بعد تعرضها
لاصابات متعدده
من السجناء السياسيين في الماضي فاذا
مصطفى
على يد الحرس الثوري في فرنسا
المهدد بالاعدام في اي لحظه فيما دعت
نائبه فرنسيه لاطلاق صلاح الشقيقين
الخطر لدى النظام الايراني المهدد بعزله
دوليه فمن
الانتفاضه قتل ما لا يقل عن 63 طفلا على
ايدي قوه الامن وفقا لاحصائيات منظمات
حقوقيه ايرانيه في معتقل الاف المواطنين
خلال التظاهرات في مدن مختلفه بينهما عدد
كبير من الاطفال والمراهقين
وباكس المشاهدين
قبل قليل الضغوط الدوليه تتزايد على
النظام الايراني
من النظام لهذه الضغوط لكن في مرحله ما هل
يمكن ان تدفعها هذه الضغوط للتراجع او
لتقديم تنازلات
تحياتي لك وعلى المشاهدين يعني
النظام الايراني فالعاده لا يتراجع كثيرا
عندما يكون بالفعل استمرار النظام في
الخطر ممكن كان هناك تراجع في مثلا سابق
عندما كان هناك ضغوط اقتصادي ولكن كان لم
يهدد كيان جمهوريه الاسلاميه ولكن الان
هناك تهديد جدي نرى اعتقلوا ممثله اللي
كانت تلعب في فيلم همم حاز على جائزه
اوسكار ترانا على دوست يعني وصلنا لمرحله
لا يتم اعتقال اشخاص معروفين اللي كنا نس-
بسبب شهرتهم على مستوى عالمي محميين حتى
تم اعتقالها بطريقه وحشيه جدا هجوم على
المنزل امام همم طفلتها صغيره في العمر تم
اعتقال يعني حتى لم يتم استحضارها الى
المحكمه يعني كان الطريق وحش جدا هذا كلها
يدل انه النظام مستمر باسلوبه القمعي وليس
لدي هي بديل اخر يتعامل مع هذه الاحتجاجات
النجوم والمشاهير لكن بملاحظ ايضا من خلال
هذه الاخبار التي تابعناها قبل قليل ان
التوتر في ايران ايضا انتقل الى اروقه
السجون همم يعني ذلك ياتي الرغم القبضه
الامنيه المحكمه او التي يريد النظام
الايراني ان يظهر او يظهر انها قبضه محكمه
لكن هل همم بدات بدات هذه السجون تشكل
بيئه خصبه لهذه الاحتجاجات في تقديرك
لانه السبب اولا انه نحن لا نعرف كم عدد
المعتقلين بالفعل بهذه السجون يعني في
هناك تقديرات فرصه 18000 شخص معتقل في
السجون بالاساس قبل هذه الصوره كانت مليئه
وكانت اكثر مما تتحمل الوضع الحالي الان
ازدياد عدد المعتقلين يعني اكيد تغير وضع
السجون بالاضافه الى اخبار ان نسمعها يعني
في ناس تم احضارها
بواسطه اشخاص لابسين ملابس مدنيه لا
يقدمون اي اوراق عن الاعتقال لا يقدمون اي
معلومات عن
السيره المحكمه لذلك اشخاص اللي موجودين
في السجن منهم ينتظرون احكام من اعدام في
بدون ما يكون هناك محاكم جديه او تعرضوا
للتعذيب لذلك لانه بسبب اعداد الكبير بسبب
هاي الاحكام الاعدامات يعني لما همم
المعتقل ليس لديه محل اخر يقوم بهذه
الاحتجاجات همم فالاخص انه هذه المعتقلين
بالعاده ناس واعرين سياسيين نعم هذه تعامل
مع السجناء يؤدي الى انفجار اللي حصل في
السجون
اليك من جديد في سياق هذه النشاط المتابعه
جمله الاخبار
الايرانيات التي فازنا بجوائز عالميه في
مجال السينما وذلك على خلفيه دعمها
لاحتجاجات حيث نشر الصوره لها دون حجاب
حامله لافته كتب عليها عباره المراه
الحياه الحريه
[موسيقى]
نشر صحيفه اليوم تايمز ما قال رايي للكاتب
الامريكي نيكولاس كريستوف اكد فيه ان احد
ابرز مظاهر نفاق النظام الايراني هو
تطبيقه قانون اخلاقيا صارما من خلال
اعتقال نساء والفتيات والمتهمات بعدم
الاحتشام ثم الاعتداء عليهن جنسيا واشار
كاتب كريستوف الى ان هيومن رئيس ووتش
ومنظمه العفو الدوليه وثقت بشكل مستقل
حالات متعدده من اعتداء الجنسي
من حاله الفتيات تتراوحو اعمارهن بين
الرابعه عشر وسته عشر عاما اعلنت وفاه
اعلنت وفاتهن بعض نقله الى المستشفيات اثر
تعرضهن الى الاغتصاب معتبر ان منع السلطات
للصحفيين الاجانب ساهم في ابقاء هذه
القضيه بعيده عن الاعين خصوصا في ظل ما
يشعر به اهالي الضحايا من مشاعر الخجل
واكدت الطواقيم الطبيه في ايران المشاركه
في الاضراب الذي يبدا غدا الاثنين
لاحتجاجا على مقتل الطبيب الشابه ايضا
رستم من محافظه كلستان
ونفى مصدر لايران اشنال سيناريو انتحار
ايضا رستومي الطبيب التي كانت تعالج جرح
الانتفاضه الشعبيه في البلاد مشر الى ان
الادله المتوفره تؤكد ان النظام الايراني
هو من قام بقتلها بعد اعتقالها وتم دفن
جثمان الطبيبه ايضا رستم يوم الجمعه فيما
كانت بعض التقارير تشكك في صحه سيناريو
الوفاء المشبهه لهذه الطبيبه في مستشفى
جمران بالعاصمه طهران
مشاهدينا اضهر مقطع فيديو متداول والدي
احد يقتل الاحتجاجات في ايران وهم يحيون
ذكرى ميلاد ابنهم ويقلقون الحماء عند قبره
وهو الطفل الذي يبلغ من العمر 16 عاما
نعيمه النوري الذي قتلته قوه النظام
الايراني قبل اكثر من شهر
[موسيقى]
بسم الله
الرحمن
[موسيقى]
هذا هو الاحتجاجات الايرانيه تتواصل حيث
نشرح حساب يدعى 1,500 تصوير يتابعه اكثر
من 40000 متابع على تويتر نشر مقطع فيديو
يظهر حشودا من المحتجين يهتفون مطالبين
باطلاق سراح السجناء السياسيين وذلك في
محطه مترو في العاصمه الايرانيه الطيران
[تصفيق]
هذا واقفه
في سجن كرج المركزي الايراني على خلفيه
شجار بين السجناء حيث هو السجناء واخرون
بالحجاره واشارت وسائل الاعلام
حول سلامه المعتقلين على خلفيه الاحتجاجات
نعود مره اخرى الى ضيفتنا من بروكسل
الباحثه في شيء ايراني من السيلاوي اهلا
بك سيد منى من جديد كما تابعنا قبل قليل
اعتقالات تطالوا المؤثرين من مشاهير ونجوم
ممثلات
ولاعبي كره القدم ما الذي يهدف اليه
النظام الايراني من هذه السياسه
والاستراتيجيه الجديده
[موسيقى]
يتكلمون بحريه اكبر كانوا ولكن عندما يتم
اعتقال بالاخص مشاهير على مستوى ترانا على
دوسي يريدون ان يخوفون الشعب يعني شهدوا
كيف شخص همم بهالدرجه واصل للمرحله
النجوميه اللي بالعاده لا يتم التعامل مع
بهذا العنف ممكن نتعامل مع بعضنا هيك عن
الاشخاص غير معروفين
طبعا كان النظام الاخر عليها لانه هي كانت
ضمن ايضا مجموعه من 800 ااه النساء اللي
كانوا داخل المجال السينما والفن الايراني
وعملوا حفله 100
اتهموا ايضا النظام وايضا الذكور
المتحكمين في السينما الايرانيه يقومون
بالتعرض للنساء يعني ليست اول مره ترانا
عليه دوست تتكلم عن قضيه حقوق المراه
وانتهاكات اللي تحصل بحق المراه وما يحصل
في السنه الايراني بسبب ذلك النظام
الايراني بالاساس نغمه عليها بسبب حديثها
عن ذكوريه المجتمع وتحكم الحكومه في
السينما
الباحث في شيء الايراني من السيلاوي شكرا
جزيلا لك يا استاذه منى
عشيه زيارته افضل وكاله الدوليه الذريه
الى طهران اعلنت ايران عن رفع قدرتها على
تقسيم اليورانيوم بدرجه كبيره واوضح رئيس
منظمه الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه
اكثر من ضعف ما كانت عليه طوال تاريخ هذه
الصناعه ومن جانبها اعانه الوكاله الدوليه
الطاقه
اليوم الاحد سعيان لتسويه ازمه تعود
لسنوات وتتعلق بالتحقيق في قضيته جزيئات
الايرانيوم التي عثر بل عثرت عليها لوكاله
في سنوات سابقه في مواقع لم تكشف عنها
طهران
نشاطنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعض الفاصل
على خلفيه قضيه تفجير لو كربي ميليشيات
الليبيه مقربه من الدبيبه متورطه في تسليم
المليمي لواشنطن
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد قال مسؤولون
الليبيون الى ميليشيا نافذه متورطه في
اعتقاله واجراء استجواب السري للمشتبه به
في تفجير لوبيربي ابو عجينه
الولايات المتحده وقال المسؤول الى الامر
بدا بنقل من منزله في حي ابو سليم بطرابلس
الذي يخضع لسيطره جهاز دعم الاستقرار وهو
عباره عن مظله ميليشيات يقودها امير العرب
عبد الغني الحالي المقرب من رئيس حكومه
الوحده
ديبابا على حده وصفهم الى تونس مشاهدينا
وفي متابعه الانتخابات البرلمانيه بدات
عمليات فرز اصوات الناخبين بعد اغلاق
المراكز الاقتراع في الانتخاب في
التشريعيه رئيس الهيئه العليا للانتخابات
فاروق معسكر قال ان النتائج الاوليه سيتم
الاعلان عنها غدا الاثنين مشيرا الى ان
نسبه المشاركه تجاوز الثمانيه
في المئه
سوف تحال محاضر الفرز على مراكز التجميع
في مقالات هيئتنا الفرعيه
لتتم معالجتها هذه الليله ويوم غد
وسوف يتم الاعلان الرسمي عن النتائج
الاوليه للانتخابات حالما يكون لدى مجلس
الهيئه كل المعطيات المتعلقه بجميع
المحاضر التجميع الصادر عن جميع هيئه
الفرعيه في تونس وخارج تونس وايضا كل
المعطيات المتعلقه بالمحاضر وبالتقارير
الخاصه بمراقبه الحمله سواء الصادره عن
اعوان مراقبه الحمله او عن هيئاتنا
الفرعيه او عن خلايا الرصد التابعه للهيئه
همم المتعلقه طبعا برصه الصحافه السمعيه
والبصريه والمكتوبه والالكترونيه والفضاء
المفتوح
مبدئيا
قد تعلن الهيئه يوم بعد يوم الغد ان شاء
الله على نتائج الاوليه بعد التثبت في كل
ذلك
طبعا الاعلان عن النتائج الاوليه يقتضي
يعني التحري في خصوص المخالفات المرتكبه
من الفائزين في شتى الدوائر
التجميع الاصوات التي ستقوم به ليله
الفرعي هو عدل الاصوات ولكن النتائج
الاوليه بما
يفترضه من تطبيق حتى لمقتل 143 وامكانيه
الغاء جزء او كل هذا من صميم صلاحيه مجلس
الهيئه بعد التثبت من كل هذه المحاضر
والتقارير
مركز الاعلامي المشاهدين تنضم الينا من
تونس الصحفيه نسرين حمداوي اهلا بك نسيم
معنا في هذه النشره
اخر التحديثات والمعطيات المتوفره حول
عمليات الفرز واعلان النتائج كذلك
امس عن النتائج الاوليه لنسب المشاركه
التي تجاوزت حدود
88% بمشاركه 800,000 ناخذ من اصل 9 ملايين
اكثر من تسعه ملايين مسجل في هذه
الانتخابات التشريعيه التي تجرى لاول مره
وفقا لمقتضيات الدستور الجديد منذ مساء
امس بعد الساعه السادسه اي موعد غلق مكاتب
الاختراع انطلقت عمليات الفارس ثم تجميع
المحاضر في مراكز الجهويه لدى الهيئات
الفرعيه للانتخابات
الصحفيه التي ستعلن خلال هيئه الانتخابات
عن النتائج الاوليه مبدئيا ثم يوم التاسع
عشر من جانفي القادم سيتم الاعلان عن
النتائج النهائيه للدور الاول ثم الدخول
في المرحله الثانيه وهي ال- ال- الحمله
الانتخابيه للدور الثاني الذي سيجري في
اكثر من 100 دائره انتخابيه وفقا لتصريح
فاروق وعسكر رئيس الهيئه العليا المستقله
للانتخابات وذلك لعدم حصول اي مترشحين على
نسبه 50 همم بالمئه زائد واحد وفقا
لمقتضيات القانون الانتخابيه الذي دخل حيز
التنفيذ منذ اشهر قليله نعم
نسرين يعني همم ابرز ملاعب هذه الانتخابات
وضعف الاقبال همم وذلك مقارنه ايضا
بانتخابات السابقه كيف بررت الاطراف
المعنيه هذا الضعف في الاقبال سواء من
اطراف الداعمه لهذه الانتخابات او
المعارضه لها
نعم بالفعل هذه اضعف نسبه اقبال على
الانتخابات 2011 في تونس رئيس هيئه
الانتخابات قال ان هذه النسبه ترجع
بالاساس الى تغيير القانون الانتخابي حيث
ان هذه المره الاولى التي يقتنع فيها
التونسيون على الافراد على الانتخاب على
قائمه حزبيه او احتلافيه او مستقله وايضا
بسبب ما وصافه بغياب المال السياسي الفا
سكانها لك عديد ردود الافعال في داخل
التونسي منظومه امس حيث اعلنت شبه الخلاص
المعارضه التي تشكلها بالاساس حركه النهضه
الاسلاميه التي قالت ان هذه اني تعكس همم
فشل مسار 25 من جوليا كمادات الى انتخابات
رئاسيه مبكرا وهو نفس الموقف ايضا الذي
اعلنت عنه
الحزب الدستوري الحر عبير مرسي التي دعت
بدورها الى انتخابات رئاسيه مبكره وايضا
تغيير تركيبت هيئه الانتخابات وهو ايضا
نفس الموقف الذي اعلنت عنه عديد الاحزاب
السياسيه في تونس التي ان هذه النسبه تمبئ
بفشل المسار الانتخابي في المقابل ايضا
حركه الشعب الداعمه لمسار 25 جويده التي
شاركت بدورها في هذه الانتخابات بمعديد
المرشحين في عدد كبير من الدوائر
الانتخابيه قالت ان هذه النسبه تعد ضعيفه
وارجع على ذلك ايضا الى نعم نعم
الانتخابات في تونس معنا الصحفيه
الاوكرانيه
على الخطوط الاماميه في اوكرانيا
الوحدات الروسيه والتحصينات وكذا الخطوط
الدفاعيه
هذا ويستعد اوكرانيون في بخموس لمواجهه
موسم شتاء قاس دون غاز او كهرباء حيث يتم
تسليم مواقد حطب
لسكان المدينه الشرقيه التي اصبحت شبه
مدمره في ما لا تزال تواجه قصفا لا هودفيه
من قبل قوات الروسيه
على الارض
ومحلات تجاريه شبه مدمره
يبدو ان هذا الشتاء سيكون الاقصى على
الاوكرانيين
في مدينه باخمد شرقي البلاد والتي تحولت
الى انقاض جراء ضربات الروسيه المستمره
على مدى اشهر متسببه انهيار الخدمات
الاساسيه من كهرباء وماء وتدفئه في صقيع
فصل الشتاء يحاول سكان المدينه مواجهه برد
الشتاء القارس بالحطب بعد افتقالهم للغاز
اضافه الى ضعف مصابيح الزيت التي لم تنجح
في تدفئتها
اكون اتوقع ان يكون الجو باردا الى هذا
الحد لكني مازلت متماسكه لدي ثلاثه مصابيح
زيت اذا كنت تعرف ما هو هذا انت صغير جدا
ربما لا تفعل ذلك لكنني اتذكر الحرب
العالميه الثانيه استخدمنا مصابيح الزيت
في ذلك الوقت ومنزلت اتذكر ذلك
ورغم قسوه الوضع الانساني الا ان بعض
الاوكرانيين ما زالوا متمسكين بالامل في
تحسن الامور
هذا نيمار
روسيا التي ركزت ضربتها العسكريه على
البنيه التحتيه للطاقه في اوكرانيا خلال
الشهر الماضي تبذل جهدها لاشهر لسيطره على
باخم التي تقاوم رغم الظروف القاسيه وصفه
مقاومه الاوكرانيين وترقب الاوروبيين وطمع
بوتين في ان يكون الشتاء فرصه لتحقيق
انتصارات جديده على الاراضي الاخرانيه
رنده الشيخ العربي
نشرتنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
في مونديال كاس العالم بقطر منتخب التانجو
بقياده ميسي يواجه ديوك فرنسا ونجمهم بابي
كاس العالم في قطر الى محطته الاخيره
وسيشهد نهائي مواجهه ثنائيه بين ميسي
من سيتزوج بطل للمونديال
في هذا الحي في ضاحيه يوسف حسين الثريه
يعيش النجم الارجنتيني ولاعب نادي باريس
سان جيرمان ليونيل ميسي
من طابقين وبمساحه 300 متر اختار ميسي هذه
المنطقه من اجل مسائل تتعلق باطفاله
بالدرجه الاولى حيث توجد هنا مدارس
امريكيه واسبانيه تسهل على الاطفال متابعه
دراستهم بلغه يتقنونها لكن ايضا لان
السكان هنا اغنياء وهذا يجعل المدينه
مقصدا للمشاهير فهنا لا يستوقفهم احد
لالتقاط الصور في الشارع كان سكان اعتدوا
على رؤيا نجوم الفن والكره وحتى السياسه
والاهم من ذلك ان ميسي لا يشعر بالوحده
هنا لانه محاط في زملاء له يسكنون في هذا
الحي مثل اخر ديماريه
[موسيقى]
اماكن تختار النجم الفرنسي العيش هنا في
الدائره السادسه عشر الافخر على الاطلاق
في العاصمه باريس في شقه تقدر قيمتها بنحو
5 ملايين ونصف المليونير بيبي يستيقظ
صباحا على اطلاله يرى منها باريس وبرج
ايفل قبل ان ينضم الى زملائه
[موسيقى]
ميسي
كوناني خصمان في الدوحه عندما تلعب
الارجنتين ضد فرنسا لكنهما سيعودان للاعب
مع ان هنا في باريس سان جيرمان وبحوزه
احدهما الكاس الاثمان كاس العالم لصباح
العربيه فادي باريس
ومن القاهره
من يرى ان هذه المواجهه والمباراه اليوم
تمثل صراعا بين جيلين الاول لنهايه مسيره
ميسي
كيف تقيم هذه المواجهه اليوم وهذا تتفق مع
هذه وجهه النظر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم بالتاكيد مباراه
اليوم هي نهائي مستحق بين
منتخبين انا اراهم الافضل في البطوله صعد
كل منهما للنهائي بمجهود وعرق وعطاء
واصرار وحرص على الوصول للمباراه النهائيه
الارجنتين خسر من المنتخب السعودي وكان
ذلك كفيل بان يترنح ولكنه وضع النهائي اا
نصبه عينيه ايضا فرنسا خسرت من تونس
ولكنها وضعت المباراه النهائيه نسبه
عينيها فانا ارى ان هذا النهائي مستحق بين
المنتخبين وهو نهائي
سيكون متوازن بالمره كلى المنتخبين لديهم
همم يعني اسلحه متوازنه اذا كان الفرنسيين
يملكون الشباب
والهجوم القوي فهناك الارجنتين تملك
الخبره وتملك الدفاع المتوازن المباراه
همم في قمه التوازن همم سيفوز بها من وجهه
نظري من تكون اخطائه قليله لان هذه
المباريات لا تتحمل ابدا الاخطاء كل فريق
له طموح فرنسا تريد ان تاخذ البطوله على
التواليل المره الثانيه على التوالي
الارجنتين تريد او ميسي بالتحديد والعالم
كله يتعاقد معه لكي ينهي حياته ببطوله طيب
وعليكم السلام يعني همم الفريق الفرنسي
فريق مدجج بهجوم قويين وسريع كما تفضلت
ولكنه ايضا في المباراه الاخيره مع المغرب
تراجع استحوالها الكره بالنسبه لسبعين في
المائه الا يدعو ذلك الفرنسيه للقلق
بالتاكيد للنهائيات حسابات حسابات اخرى
تماما اييي في المباريات ما قبل النهائي
يسعى كل فريق يعني هذه المباريات تكسب ولا
تلعب في مواجهه المغرب وصلت فرنسا الى
هدفها وهي الوصول للمباراه النهائيه فهذا
هو كان الهدف ربما كانت هناك غلبه وسيطره
للمنتخب المغربي لكن تبقى العبره
بالنهايات بالنتائج همم فرنسا همم فرنسا
فازت همم
بهدفين وهمم استطاعت ان تصل الى المباراه
النهائيه هذه الامور اعتقد ان المدير
الفني لمنتخب فرنسا يضع كل ذلك في الحسبان
اا فرنسا ترى في هذه البطوله مهمه قوميه
نحن نرى رئيس الفرنسي مكروه همم كيف حضر
مباراه قبل النهائي كيف همم تحدث مع وزيره
الرياضه الفرنسيه لجلب نجوم همم
منتخب همم فرنسي القدامى منهم بنزيما
والمصابين الحشد الهمم والوقوف خلف
المنتخب الفرنسي في هذه المباراه يغيب نعم
هذا اعتقد ان تقول يعني غياب الرئيس
الارجنتيني الى اي مدى يمكن ان يؤثر ايضا
عن على معنويات اللاعبين اليوم
اعتقد اعتقد يعني انا كنت حاضر همم نهائي
همم دوري ابطال اوروبا ليفربول وريال
مدريد واي رايته ملك اسبانيا في المباراه
النهائيه عندما يحضر الرؤساء وعندما همم
يقف خلف منتخباتهم همم تكون المهمه همم
تصل الرساله تماما للاعبين اعتقد ان ما
فعله الرئيس مكرونه هو يعني هو الصواب همم
راينا ذلك تاثير دائما القاده همم راينا
ذلك في المنتخب السعودي همم الامير محمد
بن سلمان يتواصل مع المنتخب السعودي وكل
القيادات هذه الامور بيقول لها تاثيرها
ومفعولها بالنسبه للمنتخبات نعم شكرا لك
من القاهره كنت على الناقد الرياضي جوده
ابو النور تحيه جوده
مشاهده الاخبار
العالميه كانت سلبيه جدا في الاسواق
العالميه خسائر على خلفيه اللهجه التشدديه
التي سمعناها من ثلاث بنوك مركزيه من
الاحتياطي الفيدرالي من بين كوفينج وكذلك
من البنك المركزي الاوروبي كلهم خفضوا
رفعوا الفائده بنص نقطه مئويه يعني خفضوا
من وتيره الرفع ولكن بنفس الوقت قالوا
بانه الرفع مستمر لمكافحه التضخم هذه سوق
الاسهم السعوديه بدا الجلسه على ارتفاع
الان تغيرت الصوره بعض الشيء لان هم
الاكثر ارتفاع دور وطيبه همم دوره طيبه
كان في محادثات سابقه للادماج بين
الشركتين لامر الجديده الان لانه تم احياء
هذه المفاوضات
ويبدو بانه طيبه هي التي سوف تستحوذ على
دور ااا كل مساهمين حتى الان الامر الملفت
انه ذلك سوف يكون عبر تبادل سهم وبكل سهم
بطيبه يوازي سهم بدور وهذا امر ملفت بحسب
اعلان الشركه ولكن نسبه التبادل النهائيه
سوف يتم الاعلان عنها عند اتمام الصفقه
اذا احياء
المفاوضات هذه المدرسه سوف تكون عبره
اندماج طيبه هي التي تشتري دور نذاكر هنا
بانه في مساهمين مشتركين بين شركتين يعني
محمد ابراهيم العيسى يمتلك 12% من دور
وسبعه بالمئه من طيبه اصيله للاستثمار 27%
من دول و17% من الطيبه في يمتلك بيدور
16.5 تقريبا طيب سهم بدا الجلسه على
ارتفاعات محدوده الان ما كاس تزداد السلام
على ارتفاع نسيج ماكو هذه الاسهم هي
الاكثر ارتفاعا في السوق الاكثر انتباه
وتغليف شمس ملكيه يا ريت وابوك على تراجع
البنوك متباينه في جلسه اليوم بعد ان سجلت
ارتفاعات في نهايه الاسبوع الماضي
واسهم المواد الاساسيه سابك معادن ينساب
على مكاسب في جلسه اليوم اخبار مهمه
نسمعها عن سبك توقع مذكره تفاهم مع ارامكو
ومع ساينوفيك الصينيه لدراسه الجدول
الاقتصاديه لتطوير مجمع صناعي
للبتروكيماويات متكامل مع احد المصافي
المحليه الموجوده في ينبع الصناعيه نذاكر
هنا بانه ارامكو تمتلك 70% من سبك
مشاهدينا انا اقعد معكم بعد قليل في
برنامج الاسواق العربيه لننتقل الى احمد
مجددا لمتابعه النشره
شكرا لارا في المانيا مشاهدينا الذي تشهد
احدث موجه هجره عربيه يظل تعليم اللغه
العربيه
في السنوات الاخيره خاصه الجدد الى ابقاء
اللغه العربيه حيه في اذهان اولادهم من
خلال ارسالهم الى مدارس تعلم اللغه
العربيه في عطله نهايه الاسبوع
يقرع جرس المدرسه هنا رغم انه يوم السبت
يروي الطلاب الى صفوفهم في اليوم الاول من
عطله الاسبوع في برلين الصفوف هنا ليست
اجباريه فالمدرسه هي مدرسه لتعليم اللغه
العربيه
[موسيقى]
السعوديه
الى المانيا ياتون الى هنا مره في الاسبوع
لتعلم القراءه والكتابه على لغه الام عنده
عربيه لازم اعرف احكي واكتب بالعربي
لغه الدين عندي لانه عربي ولازم اعرف
اقرا قران منيح عشان هيك لازم اعرف اقرا
عربي
التي تعلم العربيه هنا ايضا يقولون بانهم
يريدون لاولادهم ان يحافظوا على لغتهم ولا
ينسونها الاء الموجوده في دمشق وصلت الى
المانيا قبل خمس سنوات وتعلم ابنتيها
العربيه في هذه المدرسه
مسلسلاتنا برامجنا كلها باللغه العربيه
تقريبا
فما بلاقي صعوبه هنا هم كثير حابين هذا
الشعر كثير همم يمكن لانه انا عم بزرع
فيهم محبه اللغه العربيه
ومن خلال التواصل الدائمه اقرباء بالعكس
بتستمتعه يعني وثلاثه ارباع وقتهن بعدين
بالمدارس الالمانيه بتخاف مثل اي ام
بيخافوا ان اولادها ينسوا اللغه العربيه
ما عاد عندهم هالغربه فشجعوا من خلال
القصص والروايات مدرسه ابن خلدون تجذبوه
في فرعيها في برلين اكثر من 600 طالب
يدرسون في ثلاثه حصص مختلفه يوم السبت
والاحدتهم 90% من الطلبه العرب من القادم
هل يتم يرغبون التدريس ابنائهم اللغه
العربيه للمحافظه على ثقافتهم وجذورهم
وايضا همم للسهوله التواصل مع اولياء
امورهم في اقربائهم
هو يغادر الطلاب ومعهم بضعه كلمات اضافيه
كل اسبوع يامل وذويهم ان تبقى معهم حتى
يكبروا لتذكرهم بجذورهم وثقافتهم رغبهم
العربيه بلين
الساخنه في العالم وفق تقارير دوليه بسبب
الجفاف الحاد الذي يعد الاسوء منذ 40 عاما
كما ان قله المساعدات الانسانيه وغلا
الاسعار الضياء الى اغلاق مراكز التغذيه
في مخيمات النازحين ما يهدد حياه الصغار
والعجزه
قله المساعدات الانسانيه وغلاء الاسعار
الناتجه عن الحرب في اوكرانيا من اهم
العوامل التي ساهمت في تعقيد الوضع الامني
الغذائي في سمل وضع اثر صلبا في حياه
اطفال النازحين
عن هذه المخيمات بسبب نقص تمويل وغابت
معها فرحتها هؤلاء صغار الذين فقدوا مزدا
مهما كانوا يعتمدون عليه في معيشتهم تقول
رحمه جيلاني وهي ام الاثني عشر طفلنا نجحت
من منطقه بمحافظه
الاطفال
ان جميع التغذيه في هذه المخيمات اغلقا
منذ سنواته نتيجه ندره المساعدات
الانسانيه وغلاء المواد الاساسيه
عبرتي نحن كصندوق الاغاثه الافريقي فتحنا
مركزا لتغذيه الاطفال وكبار السن لكن توقف
بسبب نقص التمويل كان يعطي وجبتين ساخنتين
يوميا مكونتين من مواد مغذيه كان يستفيد
منهما 400 الى 500 شخص لكن للاسف هذا غيره
متوفر من الان ونحن في حاله جفاف عارم
غلطت ويعالج منذ سنوات من اسوا جفاف يضرب
البلاد منذ 40 عاما يرى ان ندره هطول
الامطار في اربعه مواسم متتاليه ما يهدد
حياه اكثر من سبعه ملايين شماليين بحسب
التقارير انسانيه عبد الرحمن بخاري
العربيه مقديشو
في ختام هذه الساعه
بارزه وتظاهره حاشده امام البيت الابيض
تنادي دبي المحتجين
فريق تقني يوميا الوكاله الدوليه يزور
طهران اليوم وايران تضاعف قدراتها على
تخصيب اليورانيوم
رغم الاقبال الضعيف هيئه الانتخابات
التونسيه تقول ان النسبه ايجابيه والنتائج
الاثنين
في مونديال كاس العالم بقطر منتخب التانجو
بقياده ميسي يواجه ديوك فرنسا ونجمه مبابي
[موسيقى]